[Musique]
alexeï navalni le principal opposant à
vladimir poutine est entre la vie et la
mort
hospitalisé à omsk l'homme de 44 ans
plongée dans le coma
nos médecins se bat vraiment pour lui
sauver la vie
et comme seuls responsables
disons qu'à la cei soit retiré de cet
hôpital immédiatement alexeï navalni
devenait de plus en plus une menace pour
le kremlin ce genre là il me fascine son
respect des traces on n'y peut rien ne
peut les arrêter
[Musique]
si on l'avait vraiment voulu on l'aurait
tué c'est un conflit inexpugnable sa
mort si vladimir poutine ne risque pas
la mort un de laval ni de nuit ils
veulent à risque
[Musique]
c'est véritablement un duel entre ces
deux hommes
c'est david contre goliath alexeï
navalni il a toujours détesté poutine
c'est un instrument personnel aussi
c'est un affrontement avec l'homme
kaputin alexeï navalni risque-t-il sa
vie en rentrant en russie
les gens se demandent pourquoi alexeï
navalni n'a pas encore été tués entre
fait matin peut-être sera ton tous tuer
demain ou quelque chose d'autre
m'arrivera il se sent investi d'une
mission d'un destin ou des parts et un
blogueur un juriste il s'est par la
suite vraiment immergé dans ce genre
politique
le sujet qui l'a trouvé il son principal
sujet politique c'est la corruption
ce calepin manière quand même été selon
liste noire pendant des années où son
nom selon peux pas me prononcer mais il
n'existait pas en fait au kremlin il a
immédiatement arrêté à sa descente
d'avion
nous réitérons notre appel au
gouvernement russe qui nous le
gouvernement russe doit répondre de ses
actes et jeter tragique c'est terrible
ça ne devrait pas arriver il est le
coeur du débat en permanence la bouscule
une sous ce thème lavagne est allé plus
loin que les autres
une grenade dégoupillée que le système
avaler et il est à l'intérieur
maintenant ils peuvent rien faire naval
né s'est hissé au rang que n'a jamais eu
aucun opposant russe à l'époque de poker
depuis le coeur du pouvoir nous
dirigerons la russie pour le peuple
contre ces gens merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
a moscou les autorités soviétiques
viennent de reconnaître officiellement
que 49 mille personnes ont été évacuées
autour de la centrale de tchernobyl
voilà la partie de la centrale qui
abrite le réacteur endommagé un bâtiment
en béton dont le toit est détruit les
rues semblent désertes seuls circulent
des colonnes de camions qui participent
aux opérations de contrôle et de
surveillance
je me souviens ils portaient des
combinaisons de protection chimique et
il y avait beaucoup d'ego terre partout
au début nous ne pensons pas que c'était
un accident
mais c'est l'information que nous avions
été transmise par le bouche à oreille
il n'y avait rien dans les journaux ou à
la radio le 27 avril la ville de pripiat
a été évacué et ensuite notre village d
alicia a été évacué très rapidement
après la catastrophe
on a effectué tout un rayon autour de la
centrale dont le village
alessia où se trouvait cette famille
paternelle de naval né et où il avait
l'habitude de venir en été
[Musique]
au milieu des ruines de tchernobyl
s'écrit l'histoire personnelle et
familiale d'alexei navalni de celui qui
va faire de vladimir poutine son
principal ennemi politique
cette histoire personnelle forget celle
opposant la conviction que pour
combattre
il faut être prêt à mourir à tchernobyl
exr ascaso comme alexei me disais qu'il
adorait aller là-bas l'été et à quel
point c'était mieux avant que ne
survienne la catastrophe c'est une
partie de ses souvenirs d'enfance
comme beaucoup de gens non
nous nous souvenons tous que chaque été
un garçon venait rendre visite à sa
grand mère c'était un enfant chétif
ils venaient surtout avancé neuf ans il
avait des cheveux blonds et il passait
beaucoup de temps sur les bords de la
rivière pas très loin d'ici l'arrivée en
rose comme beaucoup d'autres enfants
[Musique]
le grand-père d'alexei travailler le
bois et sa grand mère elle travaillé
dans le kolkhoze locale ils ont eu trois
fils il y avait vassil evans et anatoly
anatolie et le père d'alexane avanies
mais après l'accident ils sont souvent
venus à qualifier pour se recueillir sur
les tombes de leurs ancêtres et sur la
tombe de leur grand père alex elle n'a
pas la nostalgie de l'époque soviétique
il est assez réaliste et critiques à
propos de cette période ils prenaient
souvent en exemple gernot bill pour
montrer à quel point la désinformation
et la censure sont nuisibles et cette
situation peut tuer des gens
il a dû en effet connaître aussi bien le
drame de tchernobyl que le drame de
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alexeï navalni grandi dans un monde post
soviétique qui à l'aube du nouveau
millénaire vos l'avènement d'une figure
populaire
vladimir poutine dans l'ombre
le jeune alexei construit sa pensée
ces idées sont confuses alexeï navalni
hésitent à la recherche d'une arme
politique
les plus efficaces qui est alexeï
navalni c'est quelqu'un de très modeste
l'a vécue avec sa famille dans un trois
pièces dans un quartier périphérique de
moscou c'est un type assez ordinaire de
sa génération qui s'il était né dans un
pays qui avait donné libre cours à tous
et toutes ses capacités auraient une vie
normale de type doué de toute manière je
vais vous le dire de toute manière pour
le dire moi c'est le populisme monsieur
cakir est bien l'homme que je connais
depuis des années est un homme
sincèrement intéressé par les autres et
parce que les gens ont honte à dire
ayant vu qu'un débat parce qu'ils ont
envie de parler parce qu'il sait que le
pays dans lequel il grandit est un pays
corrompu qui ne veut pas se réformer
je vous dis aujourd'hui l'oural en
russie j'aime ce pays plus que les
faibles du coeur de voir la russie
nous allons vaincre quand il commençait
sa vie politique qui commence donc je
crois qu'il s'en cartes as 24 ans à
iabloko qui à ce moment là le parti qui
apparaît comme étant un peu le plus
visible le plus démocratique le plus
pluraliste
alex n depuis le début alexei et contre
poutine
il en parle depuis 1999 il n'aime pas
c'est pour cela qu'il s'est encartés
chez le parti libéral iabloko il le peut
virer de sortie pour nationalisme et
après il a essayé de trouver son chemin
on sait que contre les mouches les
sont efficaces et pour les
insectes sont les chaussons mais que
faire si l'insecte est un peu trop gros
et si la mouche un peu trop agressive
dans ce cas là je recommande le pistolet
cette petite vidéo c'est la propagande
du port d'armes de la possibilité
d'utiliser des armes pour l'autodéfense
blizzard nationaliste à ce moment de sa
carrière sa proximité avec les
nationalistes
je considère cela comme une erreur ce
rapprochement montre de lui une certaine
ignorance est aussi une certaine
immaturité
cette marche a lieu tous les ans c'est
un rendez vous politique elle n'a rien
de dangereux quand il se penche du côté
des nationalistes est une époque où les
nationalistes sont très bruyants et sont
aussi assez intéressant donc c'est pas
c'est pas juste des nazis et il vaut
raid et des sensibilités ou des
sympathies pour pour ses discours là
c'est que c'est des gens qui sont
intellectuellement structuré qui disent
des choses qui sont contre l'ordre et le
régime en place qui le dénonce qui sont
dans l'opposition
ce rassemblement est contre l'usurpation
du pouvoir par le gouvernement on
fricote avec eux parce que c'est curieux
ce moment-là à partir du moment où eux
sont complètement mis sur la touche et
s'éloigne des nationalistes et n'est
plus trop vu avec eux une gamme vers la
fin des années 2000
alexei lutter contre la corruption et
est devenue activiste corporatif
il se battait contre la corruption dans
les entreprises les projets de la bani
saad à bord était de médiatiser des
grandes affaires de corruption
l'économie
d'élus locaux je vais vous parler du
plus grand projet de pipeline dans
l'histoire post soviétique de la russie
le projet est dirigé par l'entreprise 39
les dépenses pour la construction ont
déjà dépassé 15 milliards de dollars
il se construit en fonction de l'air du
temps et c'est pour ça que le sujet qui
l'a trouvé et son principal sujet
politique c'est la corruption parce que
le principal problème en russie c'est la
corruption et donc c'est autour de ce
thème là qui va celui là se construit
politiquement
[Musique]
la télévision et larmes tout puissant du
kremlin
alexeï navalni lui fait un pari sur
l'avenir
internet sera son terrain d'expression
l'opposant s'apprête à ridiculiser le
pouvoir à franchir la ligne rouge
[Musique]
alexeï navalni ne se montre pas à la
télévision
ça lui est interdit on n'écrit pas au
sujet d'alex et navalni dans les
journaux en russie les médias sont
majoritairement contrôlé par le kremlin
lavagne a quand même été sur une liste
noire pendant des années où sont non
seulement on pouvait pas le prononcer
mais il était il existait pas en fait il
n'existait pas dans l'espace dans
l'espace médiatique russe
[Musique]
or si vous avez vraiment de russie je
dirais vous avez vous avez les russes
qui vont s'informer prioritairement par
la télévision
à qui appartient qui appartient à l'état
des grands conglomérats d'état et les
russes qui vont s'informer par d'autres
moyens
et là essentiellement par les réseaux
sociaux par un par un par un par
internet
l'internet russe est le lieu où la
discussion politique est extrêmement
présente parce que nous n'avons pas de
débat politique à la télévision ou à la
radio
mais sur internet nous parlons et
énormément de politique c'est l'ambition
du pouvoir russe d'être en mesure de de
souverainistes tout tout tout l'espace
numérique rencontre est loin aujourd'hui
d'un espace numérique russe très très
très cloisonné
sur l'internet
alexeï navalni cultive sa différence il
créé sa fondation anti corruption le fbk
et construit une équipe de geek
il personnifie sa communication et
dévoile une part d'intimité pour exister
le kremlin l'observent et de la colère
sans racines peu à peu contre l'opposant
alexeï navalni devient une menace mais
pacage nous allons vous montrer le
véritable patrimoine de medvedev et vous
pourrez voir par vous même qu'il est
l'une des personnes les plus riches et
les plus corrompus de notre pays
navalni et le blogueur politique le plus
populaire pour moi et je pense pour
n'importe quelle rue l'axé rallier façon
comique est très particulière pour au
moins deux raisons qui est d'abord une
connaissance très fine de tous les codes
du web
couplé à un sens de l'autodérision est
un langage très très sarcastique très
très percutant d'ombré dit bonjour
général zolotow malheureusement je n'ai
pas pu répondre immédiatement à votre
tribune parce que j'étais en prison
pendant 50 jours se considère comme un
journaliste on sans supporter de
l'information et trouve dans la
formation il expose cette information il
est un média il a une chaîne
d'information et son équipe est composée
quand même de gens très efficace je
m'appelle gorgui amoureuse moi c'est
maria pêche je suis l'aîné de volkov
yvan jdanov constituaient donc sans fond
de la lutte contre la corruption la
grande spécialité de ce faux c'est de
combattre la corruption dans les plus
hauts échelons du pouvoir russe estime
son équipe et lui sont de très bons
investigateurs ils trouvent
d'importantes quantités de preuve et en
russie sur internet nous sommes fous de
preuve avec ces années alexeï navalni a
publié des vidéos sur le premier
ministre medvedev
le procureur général shaikh a le
directeur de la garde nationale zolotow
et le directeur de russneft il est
pratiquement impossible de trouver un
homme dans l'entourage de poutine que
navalni n'a pas accusé de corruption
[Musique]
il a compris que les gens allaient tous
passés sur internet il a compris qu'en
et puis c'était surtout c'était un
espace de liberté c'était le seul espace
de liberté qui lui était complètement
accessible navalni ou bine utilisation
différents réseaux sociaux
et si on a peut-être davantage à
l'esprit sont son propre maniement du
youtube un réseau social comme comme
instagram c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important aussi dans des
draps propres stratégies downham de
navalni et s'est montré en famille il a
montré ses enfants il a montré son
épouse il a mis beaucoup en avant son
instinct grain personnel c'est son
instagram professionnels n'y a pas de
l'apab différents canaux il ya certes
aussi une dimension plus pour priver
d'instagram dans l'utilisation qu'en
fait navalni et son épouse ils viennent
d'ailleurs kiki extrêmement extrêmement
présente avec peut-être à l'accent sur
les valeurs plus traditionnelles sur le
le le cocon de sa famille
[Applaudissements]
je viens de moscou j'ai grandi je suis
né à moscou
je suis diplômée de l'académie plekhanov
en relations internationales
après mon diplôme j'ai travaillé dans
une banque plus tard il est devenu clair
qu'alexei ne penserait que politique
politique politique et moi je
m'occuperai de la famille
je vais avoir la chance de donner ma
voix
un homme en tant que femme mère et en
tant que moscovite
c'est quelqu'un de très important pour
alex et c'est la plus importante de ses
partenaires mais annonce les outils pour
moi c'est quelqu'un de très
impressionnant je vous appelle à donner
votre voix à ce candidat
il s'appelle alexeï navalni elle est
passée très discrète elle n'a pas fait
beaucoup de déclarations politiques elle
a été tout simplement toujours à ses
côtés
personnellement je n'ai jamais dit et je
ne ferai jamais quelque chose pour
essayer de le convaincre d'arrêter son
travail je le soutiens j'aime ce qu'il
fait je supporte son projet je veux
qu'il aille au bout je ne comprendrais
pas si un jour il me disait ne plus
vouloir continuer sa bataille
[Musique]
chaque pad alexeï navalni est un coup de
plus qui le rapproche de son face à face
avec vladimir poutine
l'opposant mobilisent et fait du bruit
le kremlin même pas les désordres
populaire une manifestation sans
précédent est organisée aujourd'hui
contre le résultat des élections
législatives qui ont été remportées par
le parti de vladimir poutine et il y a
déjà beaucoup de monde sur la place au
centre de la capitale russe pierre
grange oui les organisateurs comptent 50
mille personnes 50 mille personnes dans
un pays où on ne manifeste jamais et ce
ne sont pas des militants politiques qui
sont sur la place en ce moment derrière
moi ce sont monsieur madame tout le
monde des russes qui demande simplement
des élections libres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en 2011 il ya cette contestation de
vladimir poutine assez inédite
les résultats sont contestés par
beaucoup de gens et c'est un moment
aussi où les gens sont prêts en ont
marre sont fatigués ça fait ça fait 10
ans 11 ans poutine au pouvoir il va
encore rester nous peuple de russie nous
nous manifestons on n'oubliera pas on ne
pardonnera pas nous sommes solidaires
avec l'ensemble du peuple russe qui nous
écoutent et le moment où il prend un
coup il prend un micro ou non le on le
voit physiquement il sort du diane lane
i pass offline il apparaît sur scène
mais aussi dans la foule donc il est
avec les moscovites et les parmi les
moscovites
[Musique]
quelques semaines après les
manifestations contre les fraudes aux
législatives vladimir poutine vient
d'être réélu président de la fédération
de russie avec 63 6% des voix
ils entament ce jour un troisième mandat
après ce scrutin
l'opposition promet de nouvelles
mobilisations foule décor potemkine à
qui avait été mis en place dans les
années 2000 c'est à dire les apparences
fossat de la semblant de démocratie
ce décor potemkine il est
systématiquement des veut démanteler
depuis le retour de poutine au sommet du
pouvoir en 2012 pour le début de son
troisième mandat
[Applaudissements]
pendant douze ans ces gens tous les
jours nous regardent à travers la
télévision et nous disent nous allons
vous volez nous allons tricher
et hier ils l'ont fait encore une fois
[Musique]
alexeï navalni jouent le jeu du système
et se mue en homme politique l'opposant
se présente à des élections
la mairie de moscou puis l'élection
ultime la présidentielle chaque
candidature est une marche gravi pour
attendre son ennemi dans un face-à-face
présidentielle inédit pour un opposant
alexeï navalni défi vladimir poutine sur
son terrain politique
nous présentons à ces élections car nous
savons comment combattre la corruption
sa vraie performance ce thème quand il
était venu se présentait contre le maire
de moscou
et là elle avait son côté fonceur
ce quelqu'un qui fait une performance
nous savons comment aider les retraités
nous savons comment améliorer
l'éducation et le système de santé et
nous sommes prêts à le faire maintenant
[Musique]
l'idée que se faisait le kremlin
eq alexeï navalni ne pourrait pas
recueillir beaucoup de voix que cette
campagne prouverait qu'il en soutien
très bas et que ce serait donc la fin de
la carrière politique d'alexina vague
mais la campagne fut un réel succès
[Musique]
et allez dans les cours d'immeubles et
parler aux familles aux jeunes et ça
crée un réseau horizontal ce qui
n'existait pas la verticale du pouvoir
qui se renforcer à ce moment là était
complètement impuissante face à ça
[Musique]
le premier tour sergueï sobianine est
officiellement élu maire de moscou
depuis des protestations de nombreux
analystes sont d'accord pour dire que la
percée d'annexer navalni et sa seconde
place à l'élection sont un très bon
résultat
ce n'est sûrement pas la dernière fois
que nous entendons parler de lui et en
fin de compte
malgré les obstacles dressés par le
kremlin il a obtenu 27 % des voix
d'après les résultats officiels navale
n'est s'est hissé au rang que n'a jamais
eu aucun opposant russe à l'époque le
clip qui n'a pensé comment mettre en
route notre machine politique
nous sommes un rouleau compresseur qui
va écraser le parti du pouvoir surtout
90 personnes réunies donc sur la place
bolotnaïa et ils étaient quelque chose
qui m'a énormément marqué mes amis je ne
pourrais pas être re mr mais vous savez
que ce n'est pas après l'ambition moi je
vise plus haut
je vise là il montre la muraille du
kremlin
et il dit là derrière cette muraille et
un crapaud et bien je ferai tout mon
possible pour que les températures
deviennent tel qu'il tombe
nous ferons tout pour franchir les murs
du kremlin
juste là depuis le coeur du pouvoir nous
dirigerons la russie pour le peuple
nous ferons tomber ces gens merci à tous
où prend une vraie existence prend une
vraie naissance politique à ce moment là
et il devient dangereux à ce moment là
[Musique]
les élections arrivent dans peu de temps
et je me présente en face de l'actuel
président je me suis longtemps demandé
si je devais participer
je sais à quel point il est dur de faire
campagne face à lui les idées
principales de sa campagne sont la
démocratie le respect des droits
la concurrence et l'ouverture évidemment
la construction de son image
il se construit comme un anti poutine
aussi quand je serai président je ferai
en sorte que tout cet argent ne soit pas
volée à l'époque on voit que c'est
quelqu'un qui a de plus en plus de
visibilité
c'est à ce moment là aussi qu'il qu'il
sort de moscou et que lui découvre le
pays plus et que le pays le découvre et
c'est une rencontre importante avec avec
la russie
on avoir largué non à vaslui à de
nombreux activistes dans la majorité des
régions russes ses bureaux régionaux
commencé à essaimer dans le pays
il commence à grignoter la carte
électorale russe
[Musique]
l'opposant alexeï navalni ne pourra
finalement pas se présenter à la
présidentielle sa candidature a été
rejetée par la commission électorale il
dénonce la mainmise de vladimir poutine
sur le pays
le condamne pour lui à faire du temps de
mon argent il ne peut plus participer à
la présidentielle mais il n'arrête pas
sa campagne
donc il est quand même il reste
extrêmement actif d'un wright descendons
dans la rue pour nous mêmes pour nos
droits pour notre avenir
des manifestations doivent être
organisées dans tout le pays le 28
janvier
[Musique]
immobilise la ruée continue à faire
parler nuisent pas les bras il se range
pas il se dit pas bon ce sera grave je
participerai ce que temps après
[Musique]
suivez moi de l'autre côté de la rue
le kremlin contre attaquer les affaires
judiciaires se multiplient pour alexeï
navalni depuis 2011 le blogueur aura
passé plus de deux cents jours en prison
aujourd'hui un nouveau coup dur vient le
frapper l'opposant et sa fondation anti
corruption le fbk viennent d'être
classées agents de l'étranger par la
justice russe de nombreuses
organisations américaines ou européennes
sont qualifiés d' indésirables et
communiquer avec elle est un crime est
une infraction pénale en russie c'est un
contrôle fiscal à creux et c'est aussi
extrêmement péjoratif parce que ceux qui
ont été reconnus par les mystères de la
justice en tant qu'agent étrangers sont
obligés de l'affiché partout
navalni dans réalité est discrédité
russie part ça parce qu'il ya quatre
ception des russes ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est soutenu par le les
occidentaux hier en zone naturelle
je suis une personne raisonnable
je comprends à qui j'ai affaire et je
sais de quoi est capable le kremlin et
tout ce groupe de corrompus du kremlin
qui ont à leur service des légions de
tueurs qui n'hésitent pas à assassiner
les enquêtes à répétition les
provocations récurrentes puis les
candidatures à des élections
le battage lancinant de l'opposant a
définitivement agacé le kremlin
une seule solution le faire taire c'est
véritablement donc un duel entre ces
deux hommes
[Musique]
alexeï navalni le principal opposant à
vladimir poutine est entre la vie et la
mort
hospitalisé à omsk l'homme de 44 ans est
plongé dans le coma
ses proches parlent d'un empoisonnement
et désigne le kremlin comme seuls
responsables
[Musique]
à l'heure actuelle les docteurs font
tout leur possible
il se bat vraiment pour lui sauver la
vie
[Musique]
au mini est j'ai des informations
précises selon lesquelles le principal
problème est qu'ils empêchent l excès de
sortir d'ici nous exigeons qu'elle
essaye soit retiré de cet hôpital
immédiatement pour que nous puissions
l'emmener chez le médecin en qui nous
avons confiance
[Musique]
alexeï navalni devenait de plus en plus
une menace pour le kremlin toutes ces
années les gens se demandaient pourquoi
alexeï navalni n'a pas encore été tués
il ya une très grande tradition
d'assassinât avec le tgb avec le service
secret fument les gens veulent associer
une de ces gens là ils soutiennent sans
laisser de traces d'expérience sûrs que
nos services secrets le suivait de près
ça veut pas dire que nous voulions
proposer des si on l'avait vraiment
voulu on l'aurait tué c'est un conflit
inexpugnable sa mort si vladimir poutine
ne risque pas la mort de la vanille de
l'huile à la risk je n'avais aucun doute
sur le fait qu'il était empoisonnée par
le kremlin et il ya ben j'étais
horrifiée mais je ne peux pas dire que
j'étais surpris je pense que une
nouvelle fois la vère navalni vient
mettre en lumière la réalité pas de ce
régime
la réalité bas de la personne de poutine
nous sommes évidemment extrêmement
préoccupé et attristé par la situation
d'alexandre navalni et nous avons appris
ce matin ce qui lui était arrivé je ne
sais pas précisément ce qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose mais c'est tragique
c'est terrible ça ne devrait pas arriver
[Musique]
nous avons pris la décision de ne pas
nous opposer à son transfert il pourra
être transportés vers un autre hôpital
celui que ses proches choisir
[Musique]
nous avons organisé le vol et
heureusement après plusieurs obstacles à
surmonter ça a finalement bien
fonctionné et le patient est arrivé à
berlin un homme de l'ombre joue un rôle
clé dans le rapatriement de l'opposant
russe yak abhisit lui c'est un majeur et
la logistique et à mobiliser la classe
politique européenne pour évacuer alexeï
navalni de russie vers berlin en 48
heures il est devenu l'acteur
stratégique de ce que l'on nomme
désormais la ferme avanies
[Musique]
ce soir c'était le 20 août 2020 je me
suis réveillé vers 10h30 ce matin là les
pussy riot m'avait laissé un message y'a
car notre ami alexeï navalni vient
d'être empoisonné peux-tu nous aider
parce deux ans avant j'avais fait
rapatrier piotr vers seelow depuis
moscou
elle me demandait de faire la même chose
pour alexeï navalni c'est pour ça
qu'elles m'ont appelé je n'ai pas fait
ça pour des raisons politiques mais pour
des raisons humanitaires
on travaille alors consister à savoir si
l'hôpital de la charité accepteraient
d'accueillir une personnalité politique
importante après avoir eu la
confirmation qu'ils accueilleraient
navalni j'ai dû réfléchir à comment
rassembler une équipe médicale et un
avion privé pour le sortir de là en fait
il ya cette famille russe qui vit à
londres
la famille mines qui a pris en charge
les frais du vol et son traitement à
l'hôpital de la charité a été pris en
charge par trois autres amis russes
m
[Musique]
notre accord était que notre avion
devait atterrir le matin à omsk et
repartir immédiatement en allemagne avec
mon interlocuteur à omsk il est devenu
rapidement évident que cet accord ne
serait pas tenu et j'ai dû mobiliser
tout le monde mobilisé les politiques
est donné dans le même temps une
conférence de presse avec leonid volkov
à berlin notre demande reste la même
nous devons l'emmener dans un endroit à
berlin à l'hôpital de la charité ou une
analyse indépendante pourra être fait
nous voulons vraiment savoir ce qui lui
est arrivé après mon message angela
merkel elle a donné une conférence de
presse après une rencontre avec macron à
midi au cours de laquelle merkel et
macron tous les deux proposé une aide
médicale alexeï navalni en france ou en
allemagne
m
on fait un sport ce qui vaut pour la
france vaut aussi pour l'allemagne nous
lui offrons bien sûr toute l'aide
médicale nécessaire il peut se tourner
vers nos hôpitaux du harper's maj je
sais avec certitude que sans réaction de
la part d'angela merkel et d'emmanuel
mâcon le 20 août en 2020 alexeï navalni
n'aurait jamais pu partir il y a
plusieurs éléments différents qui se
sont additionnés avant de recevoir un
message étonnant nous autorise enfin à
décoller
[Musique]
l'avion a atterri à berlin à 8h47
le matin nous étions soulagés là nous
avons constaté que son état de santé
était plutôt stable
[Musique]
le poisson par lequel la vallée a été
empoisonnée selon l'avis de trois
laboratoires indépendants allemands
suédois et français appartient au groupe
de poison nourriture
maintenant bien sûr les russes ni ses
indications avec senna banny alexeï
navalni a été victime d'une attaque avec
un agent neurologiques chimique du cros
des novices choc
il y à des questions très sérieuses
auxquelles seul le gouvernement russe
peut répondre le sort d'alexina vanik
attire l'attention du monde entier
nous n'avons rien à cacher concernant
les accusations de madame merkel qui
nous rend responsable cette action de ce
soi-disant empoisonnement mais ne peut
présenter aucune preuve les propos
déclamatoire est retentissant de nos
collègues occidentaux suscite un certain
scepticisme de notre part
[Musique]
à l'étranger l'opposant russe alexeï
navalni a donné de ses nouvelles et
après plusieurs semaines dans le coma il
va beaucoup mieux il a même posté lui
même quelques photos depuis son hôpital
berlinois de leur côté vous allez le
voir ses soutiens ont aussi mené leur
propre enquête pour prouver son
empoisonnement par les services secrets
russes les junk food le président
poutine ne pouvais pas nier et a
pratiquement confirmé que les huit
magnifique qui m'avait suivi pendant
presque quatre ans étaient des officiers
du fsb
bien entendu nos agences connaissent sa
géolocalisation
ils savent donc très bien où il est si
j'étais suivi parce que je suis un
extrémiste alors pourquoi le faire par
des médecins et des chimistes ouattara
lors de ses recherches avec bing cat
il s'est rendu compte que l'état et le
kremlin était impliqué et qu'il y avait
une équipe de tueurs du fsb chargé de le
suivre depuis des années et
effectivement c'est eux qui ont essayé
de le tuer cette enquête est le fruit
d'une collaboration avec bell incat
insider cnn el país ou der spiegel
belinga tu avais une liste de numéros de
téléphone qu'ils ont appelé eux mêmes le
plan est simple vous recevez un appel à
7 heures du matin vous voyez un numéro
familier vous décrocher le téléphone et
commençait à parler
presque tous ceux que j'ai appelés ont
répondu et presque tous ont raccroché
rapidement et puis la chance allait nos
sourires vague
we are thème bonjour constantine
constantine boris au beach je dois juste
écrire un rapport rassemblant les
témoignages des membres de ton équipe
que s'est il passé pourquoi l'opération
à tomsk a échoué le voyage a été
raccourcie l'avion avait atterri à
l'heure prévue
tout aurait été différent quelle était
la procédure que devez vous faire je
dois faire un rapport nous lui avons
appliqué le produit il les a ridiculisé
en discutant au téléphone avec l'un de
saison 3 honneur ça commence à faire
beaucoup tant qu'il ne faisait que jouer
un peu aux élections ou un petit peu
participé à des manifestations ou
dénoncer la corruption d'un gouverneur
secondaire c'était toléré mais
maintenant qu'ils s'attaquent aux
services de sécurité trop c'est trop
[Musique]
j'ai acheté des billets pour rentrer
donc le dimanche 17 janvier
je serai de retour à moscou
[Musique]
alexeï navalni refusent l'exil son
retour en russie est une décision
inédite pour un opposant au kremlin
mais jairo ski ou de garry kasparov ont
préféré l'exil à la prison ou un sort
plus funestes son retour est une
provocation de plus l'opposant ne se
déclare pas vaincu il ira au bout de ses
duels
quitte à braver la main la vanille est
allé plus loin que les autres accords
aux drogues ch'ti ou un certain nombre
d'oligarques et qui ont cherché à
résister à ce rouleau compresseur au
début des années 2000
et puis qui soir concédé pas ou alors eh
bien ils se sont exilés à londres ou
ailleurs en russie un homme politique de
l'opposition risque sa vie et sa alexei
l'a très bien compris
alexeï navalni risque-t-il sa vie en
rentrant russie ou provocation pour le
kremlin qu'il l'a immédiatement arrêté à
sa descente d'avion
que voulez-vous inspectés pourquoi la
retenue vous retenez mon avocate
mais pour qu'elle enquête lancée des
moments et décide de rentrer en russie
on comprend assez clairement qu' il va
passer par la case prison
pourquoi vous ne bloquez c'est dans
votre intérêt de me laisser passer avec
lui je n'ai jamais douté qu'il rentrera
en russie il se sent investi d'une
mission
et surtout il croit en son destin
il est allé avec le visage découvert
pour confronter son adversaire
l'admirent poutine
[Musique]
emprisonné depuis moins de 48 heures
alexeï navalni des ghana coup politique
un séisme deux heures dans quête d'un
film intitulé un ballet pour poutine
deux heures de cours contre le président
russe l'opposant de fil aux arçons soit
semblant alexeï navalni n'a plus rien à
perdre
[Musique]
bonjour c'est navalni nous avons
commencé cette enquête lorsque j'étais
en soins intensifs et nous savions
immédiatement que nous la publions à mon
retour en russie à moscou
nous ne voulons pas que le personnage
principal de ce film pense que nous
avons peur de lui et que je raconterai
son pire secret depuis l'étranger l'un
de nos spectateurs et l'admirateur le
plus dévoué de notre travail celui qui a
ordonné devant foisonner vladimir
poutine le documentaire a été diffusé
sur youtube pour youtube finalement avec
un format là aussi très travaillé dans
des mises en scène et qu'il est mis à
profit pendant soit sa convalescence à
berlin
[Musique]
je crois qu'il a fait ce film que
c'était aussi une sorte de sa vengeance
personnelle parce que ils considèrent
que c'est poutine en personne qui a
donné l'ordre de l'éliminer il ya une
grande habilité scénaristique
je dirais de sa part notamment par un
par des formules qui qu'il compare au
roi soleil à quelqu'un de totalement
déconnecté du réel et de la vie des dix
citoyens russes
[Musique]
poutine un petit officier du kgb qui se
fait maintenant passer pour un grand
espion est venu à dresde en 1985 il veut
qu'on le considère comme un fils très
cool mais en fait il était un employé
ordinaire même pas d'une résidence
secrète mais du bureau de représentation
officielle du kgb en allemagne de l'est
ami de l'union soviétique est un
affrontement personnel aussi c'est un
affrontement avec poutine en tant que
représentant du pouvoir mais avec
l'homme kaputin l'installation la plus
secrète et la plus garder de russie sans
exagération n'est ni une maison campagne
date chaîne une résidence c'est une
ville entière ou plutôt un royaume elle
a des clôtures imprenable son propre
corps ses propres gardes une église son
propre contrôle d'accès une zone
d'interdiction de vol et même son propre
poste de contrôle frontalier
il s'agit d'un véritable état distinct
au sein de la russie est dans cet état
il ya un roi unique et irremplaçable
poutine comme à nîmes autres ses
richesses d'une part il provoque de
l'indignation
mais d'autre part quelque part il
provoque possible peut-être une
fascination parce que les gens ils
avancent
voilà ça c'est les vrais maîtres du pays
c'est bien en effet en russie il existe
une tradition selon laquelle le
dirigeant doit posséder certains signes
de grandeur quelques objets spéciaux pas
si cher nous montre parfaitement le
monde dans lequel vit poutine état et un
lien voici une brosse de toilette
italienne qui vaut 700 euros ou soixante
deux mille roubles et gagnaient bien
entendu les citoyens russes se sont
révoltés du fait que la brosse à
toilettes soit plus cher que le revenu
mensuel de 90 % des citoyens russes est
la première fois le nom de la vanille
est prononcé dix fois par jour sur des
chaînes que l'on n'avait jamais autorisé
à le faire et qu'ils n'ont jamais fait
il est le coeur du il est le coeur du
débat en perdre
il a bousculé un système il a fait peur
au système surtout fait que beaucoup de
vent beaucoup de gens ont vu le film
depuis de nombreuses années navalni se
bat pour nos droits
maintenant il est temps pour nous de
nous battre pour lui 23 janvier 14h
descendez dans les rues ne restez pas à
l'écart le bruit de la rue se cumulent
au nombre de vue du film un palais pour
poutine de moscou à vladivostok
les manifestants bravent les
arrestations de masse depuis sa prison
alexeï navalni fait trembler les murs du
kremlin
mais le pouvoir reste inflexible de
chill proviendra le prochain coup
le duel prendra fin ce café navalni
c'est le plus grand exemple de
patriotisme donne à voir publier cette
enquête sur le palais qu'une fois revenu
en russie
pour lui ce qui est le plus important
c'est de montrer qu'il n'a pas peur et
qu'ils n'essayent pas de sketches l
étranger c'est pour ça que le 23 janvier
j'ai été manifesté pour la première fois
de ma vie son principal message c'est
n'ayez pas peur et ça c'est quelque
chose de très important parce que
personne ne l'a dit comme lui aussi fort
depuis longtemps lorsque l'excès une
avanie publis au film sur poutine c'est
la goutte d'eau qui a suscité une
réaction de beaucoup de citoyens russes
et on est tous descendus dans la rue
je suis allé à cette manifestation
non pas parce que je supporte un côté ou
l'autre
en vérité la raison principale est mon
ras-le-bol du modèle politique actuelle
et du fonctionnement de ce gouvernement
la chose qui m'a étonné le plus pendant
ces manifestations c'est qu'il y avait
beaucoup de monde
contrairement à d'habitude
[Musique]
il requiert pour être honnête
avant ça je ne pensais pas qu'on pouvait
arriver à une telle situation qu'un
gouvernement puisse essayer de tuer un
des citoyens de son pays avec une arme
interdite
aujourd'hui c'est lui demain ça peut
être toi même pour le système judiciaire
russe et l'acharnement de l'état contre
un seul homme c'est quelque chose de
totalement il ya je ne m'arrêterai pas
je continuerai d'y aller jusqu'à ce que
quelque chose change d'une manière ou
d'une autre je vais essayer de faire
changer les choses
merci nous avons internet on voit ce qui
se passe dans les autres pays on
comprend que certaines choses sont mieux
ailleurs et nous voulons la même chose
pour nous ici en russie
[Musique]
les amis des deux manifestations
consécutifs n'ont pas influencé le
tribunal de moscou deux ans et huit mois
de prison ferme pour alexeï navalni le
kremlin assène un coup décisif
les discussions des chancelleries
occidentales n'entrave en rien la
détermination du pouvoir russe les
histoires de l'opposant s'assombrissent
question pareille c'est est-ce qu'ils
allaient à remonter une des nouvelles
charges d'un nouveau un nouveau procès
hausse qu'ils allaient ressortir ce qui
était déjà déjà là comme ils sont très
paresseux ils n'ont pas pris la peine de
de rebâtir une affaire contre lui il est
vrai grain de sable à l'échelle
nationale avec un impact pour l'instant
limités mais à l'échelle internationale
l'effet delà de la sphère navalni a été
de de lui donner une importance
stratégique et de la placer au centre
des relations entre l'occident et la
russie
les occidentaux cherchent quelqu'un
qu'il pourrait investir aussi faire le
héros un qui pourrait soutenir contre
poutine
nous réitérons notre appel au
gouvernement russe afin de libérer
immédiatement et sans conditions
monsieur navalni ainsi que les centaines
d'autres citoyens russes injustement
arrêtés ces dernières semaines pour
avoir simplement exercé leurs droits
il se trouve que tout le monde se
mobilise pour lui que à l'international
on se mobilise pour lui les hommes
politiques les chancelleries qu'il n'y a
rien de qui puisse énerver plus le
kremlin que ces types-là de pression
c'est dans un contexte tendu que le chef
de la diplomatie européenne josep
borrell rencontre le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov
les relations sont au plus bas entre
l'union européenne et la russie depuis
la condamnation d' alexeï navalni watts
mais sous des cartons
nous avons constaté la volonté de
coopérer de manière pragmatique
lorsqu'il ira à l'intérêt est un
avantage mutuelle nous sommes tous
d'avis qu'une dégradation supplémentaire
de nos liens peut avoir des conséquences
négatives est assez imprévisible pour la
branche
il n'est pas question de discuter avec
les pays européens de la question des
droits de l'homme
et donc fort logiquement pas de celle de
navalni les occidentaux nous n'irons pas
contre 20 n'iront pas la guerre ouverte
avec moscou et surtout pour une histoire
de politique intérieure ce qu'il
considère quand même pour l'instant
comme de la politique intérieure n'y
aura jamais de paix de sécurité et de
stabilité sur le continent européen
si nous n'avons pas une discussion
exigeante et des résultats avec la
russie
je dois admettre que le système carcéral
russe a réussi à me surprendre
je ne pouvais pas imaginer qu'il était
possible d'organiser un véritable camp
de concentration à 100 km de moscou
il est en prison il se sent mal il se
sent de plus en plus mal on la crée des
conditions assez inconfortable voyant
aujourd'hui il souffre on le torture en
prison il n'a pas accès aux soins
médicaux on le laisse pas dormir
peut-être qu'ils ne le feront pas en
prison mais ils peuvent le rendre très
malade
rien ne peut les arrêter
alexeï navalni débute une grève de la
faim dans une lettre publiée sur son
compte instagram le 31 mars
l'opposant annonce l'arrêt de son
alimentation une façon de protester
contre la dureté de ses conditions de
détention alexeï navalni demande
également une assistance médicale
après plus de deux mois de prison son
état de santé se dégrade
mon mal de dos s'est déplacée vers ma
jambe des parties de ma jambe droite est
maintenant de ma jambe gauche ont perdu
toute sensation au lieu d'une aide
médicale je suis torturé par la
privation de sommeil ils me réveillent
huit fois par nuit alors qu'est-ce que
je peux faire
j'ai déclaré une grève de la faim avec
sa grève de la faim
j'ai compris que ça n'était pas une
décision hâtive alexeï navalni a
toujours dit que lors d'une grève de la
faim il fallait aller jusqu'au bout il
est important de savoir qu à l'excès est
un homme très croyant je pense que pour
lui il est plus important de bien agir
que de rester en vie nous demandons aux
autorités russes de prendre toutes les
mesures nécessaires pour s'assurer de sa
sécurité et de sa santé tant qu'il est
en prison le gouvernement russe est
responsable de sa santé et de son
bien-être
nous continuerons de suivre la situation
de près
navalni qui en prison qui arrivent plus
à marcher et qui dit n'ayez pas peur
d'ailleurs je vais arrêter de manger
c'est un message très fort même les gens
qui ont séjourné au poste qui sont ceux
qui ont séjourné en détention au mois de
janvier
ça les a pas dissuadés de sortir
maintenant parce que ça ce n'est plus là
[Musique]
après 20 jours sans alimenter alexeï
navalni annonce mettre un terme à sa
grève de la faim
l'opposant russe a obtenu gain de cause
très affaibli il a été transféré il ya
quelques jours dans une nouvelle prison
au sein de laquelle ils bénéficient d'un
suivi médical mini citadine bon je ne
vais pas rester à la maison à boire du
thé à penser peut-être se racontent tous
tuer demain ou quelque chose d'autre
arrivera ne rien faire serait stupide et
absurde
je fais de la politique depuis longtemps
je suis souvent arrêtés ou suivi quelque
part donc c'est juste une partie de ma
vie
[Musique]
le scénario qu'il raconte autour de ces
accords c'est un scénario à l'amendé la
liberté ils passent des années un tollé
après il vient sur le cheval blanc en
russie c'est la politique fiction
c'est une grenade dégoupillée que le
système avaler et il est à l'intérieur
maintenant ils peuvent rien faire il a
forcé le système qui ne voulait pas de
lui qui essayait sans cesse de le
recracher il a forcé système à la vallée
et maintenant il est dedans il le
parasite de l'intérieur j'ai 23 ans j'ai
passé 20 ans de ma vie avec un seul
président j'aimerais vraiment qu'un jour
cette situation change mandat actuel ne
prend fall théoriquement eu en 2024 sa
phrase un quart de siècle qu'il est à la
tête de la russie
[Musique]
on peut plus parler poutine sans parler
de la vanille on peut parler de russie
sans parler de la vanille c'est très
récent
depuis justement cet empoisonnement son
retour en réussit son incarcération et
tout ce qui se passe maintenant qu'on
peut dire qu'il ya deux personnalités
maintenant russie il ya bladi mercantine
et alex et la vanille
[Musique]
alexeï navalni a bousculé la scène
politique russe
son adversaire l'a dit mir poutine reste
le maître du jeu mais par son action
l'opposant à semer les graines de la
révolte au sein d'une partie de la
population russe ces graines germées
rond elle ou alexeï navalni restera-t-il
une comète de l'opposition seul le temps
l'on désignera le vainqueur du duel
[Musique]
oh